what's going on guys this is rob and we
are here with what's probably the most
entertaining story from spider-verse
which is miles morales and spider-man
from the ultimate spider-man cartoon
show meet spider-man for the 1960s
cartoon show and it's amazing i love
this story
it's just so much fun right it's just a
fun story to read so as we as we kind of
mentioned in the last video right
they're miles and we're just going to
call them ultimate spider-man it's just
easier that way but miles an ultimate
spider-man basically ended up in this
universe because they're basically
trying to find more spider-man and this
year i mean it's basically what it was
you know what you saw in the cartoon
show right where it's pretty straight
forward there's like only one building
with a sign on it and that sign is daily
bugle so they know like exactly where to
go to find spider-man but like jay jonah
jameson he's hilarious in this right so
he's like pay attention parker he's like
we've had reports of two spider-man
swinging around making spectacles of
themselves and peter's like two
spider-man he's like do you know what
that means parker and he's like well i
don't know i mean criminals have been
personally spider-man before he's like
balderdash the web-headed menace finally
showed his true colors he's put together
a gang of crooks to terrorize the city
get me proof
[Laughter]
j jonah jameson became americans in the
21st century i have a conclusion now i
need evidence to support it
and it's just like okay right jonah
jameson so anyway you end up picking up
with ultimate spider-man and miles of
course as they're on the hunt for for 60
spider-man and ultimately they find him
but as you guys if any of you guys ever
saw the 1960 spider-man cartoon and if
you didn't it was amazing dude
old-school spider-man was hilarious but
this episode was actually based off a
story called to catch a spider right
which was basically dr noah body who
essentially unleashes like electro and
like green goblin and these guys to take
out spider-man but unlike the the
original show the original cartoon this
basically takes place in instead or at
least uh partly takes place in instead
so what goes on here and it's kind of a
funny thing is uh miles and ultimate
spider-man are talking to like 60
spider-man right 60 spider-man's like
okay you imposters can unmask and
surrender right now or i can web you up
and we'll do it at the police station
your choice chums now ultimate
spider-man is hilarious here right
because he's like okay stay back miles i
got this man like i'm well-versed in in
this kind of talk so he's like get hip
to this daddy-o there's a heavy scene
going down and we ain't got time for a
lot of rama-lama ding-dong you dig and
60 spider-man's like the hard way it is
and like
he webs him up
now at that point miles comes in and
miles was like no you got the wrong idea
man he's like we're spider-man from a
different dimension and then like uh and
then like like literally that's what he
says right he's like we're spiderman
from like other dimensions there's like
like a giant menace that we have to deal
with and we need help and like 60
spider-man's like oh well why didn't you
just say so that explains everything
it was it was hilarious because at that
point in time like the the way
spider-man was depicted is he was just
so i don't know maybe naive or something
like that but it was it was almost kind
of adorable right it was kind of funny
plus he would complain a lot in the
1960s show he would complain all the
time i mean i guess technically was a
1967 show but like he would complain a
lot he'd be like i'm hot in my
spider-man suit and swinging around is
making me even hotter and these stupid
villains are escaping now i'm gonna have
to beat him to death like he would
complain all the time but again the
whole thing ends up kind of playing out
where he's like okay cool like i'll go
with you guys to go on this great big
huge adventure but i need to take up
this thing first right this guy dr noah
body has basically released the vulture
and electro and green goblin and
scorpion and i gotta deal with them
first right now here's the funny thing
as soon as these guys show up i mean
it's designed to look like the 60s show
so like they look goofy and they look
kind of silly and whenever green goblin
was riding around on his goblin glider
in like the 60s cartoon it looked like
he was powering it by farts not even
gonna lie but the whole thing about that
is of course they're they're able to
overpower them momentarily but mr noah
body who's basically invisible has like
this ray gun that basically
incapacitates them and then the villains
do what they always did in the show
which was bigger amongst themselves and
then ultimately get themselves caught
now in that whole thing where this this
whole kind of situation is going on like
60 spider-man's like with the last time
i beat him i use ventriloquism but i
don't know if that'll work this time and
of course it ends up coming by way of
ultimate spider-man who basically webs
up their legs and then essentially takes
out mr noah body which you know allows
miles morales to you know kind of step
up and then you know use his venom blast
to electrocute mr noah body and take him
out and all those guys are defeated and
basically the day is saved and then you
get to what's quite possibly one of the
more questionable moments of the comic
which i guess it kind of depends on on
which direction you're coming from but
basically once they're all together it's
almost like the old throwback to like
the 19 or to the old justice league
right like when they all masked and they
all learn their identities but basically
like ultimate spider-man reveals his
identity as peter parker and then miles
morales reveals his identity and then
like 1960 spider-man's like walloping
web snappers i mean he doesn't say like
like he's not
it's not like he's like you're black
like it's not anything like that he's
just like surprised he's a high school
kid but like christos gage was kind of
going with that right kind of like you
know building up to that little bit of
comedy and ultimate spider-man's like oh
snap man tell me that like the 1960s
spider-man is an old-fashioned in all
the bad ways too you know but ultimate
and it's one of those things where miles
was kind of expecting it right miles is
kind of like all right i'm gonna take
off this mask in front of this 1960s
white dude we're gonna see what happens
right and then you know he's like
walloping web snappers and i was like
man don't you say it he's like you're a
high school kid mom's like awesome dude
i'm not gonna have to beat the hell out
of you
because i'll be honest man i feel like
miles would have dude miles would have
beat the tar out of this guy like say
what you would have just lost it on him
it would have been hilarious well he
would have totally lost it on him but
nonetheless the two of them basically
end up going forward and bringing in
like 1960 spider-man as a way to
basically combat the inheritors but yeah
okay now this is something else that i
also want to point out here um so the
way these quite a verse team up stories
were done is they were basically a-side
stories and b-side stories you
essentially get part one then you get
part two so if you guys want in the
future stories that we do or the future
videos that we do we can cover both
parts let me know if you guys want to
see both parts in a single video or if
you want to focus on like just each
individual part as its own video and let
me know what you guys are interested in
seeing but with that being said guys
we're going to bring this video to an
end thank you guys for watching and i
will catch you all later
peace